alright so here to talk to you guys
today about blazing odo my name is
phillip cloud I work for continuum
analytics I spend part of my time doing
open source most of which goes towards
blaze and odo a little bit on task and
then pandas when something doesn't work
in blazing odo because of pandas which
is rare but it does happen alright so
let's just dive right in
place so what is blaze it's an interface
for data centric computation it's
composed of two things expressions and
compute recipes where does look like pro
sorry what does where's blaze or sit in
the in the PI data ecosystem many many
systems have a two level architecture
they have an interface and they have an
implementation numpy has an API that
sits in Python which wraps a lot of its
low level c code operating directly at
the byte level pandas are something
similar and but instead of using see it
uses mostly scythe on there's a bit of C
for the CSV parser but it's mostly
incite them but the user the user
doesn't really see those those psyphon
bits they kind of are only using data
frame series which are all pure python
code
there's similar trends in other other
systems right you you don't actually
really delve into the details of your my
sequel database or how MongoDB stores
things you there's a language for it in
sequel in the sequel database case its
sequel and mongodb has its own query
language and then the amount of
computing or something similar and world
blazes is it's only an interface it
doesn't just actually implement any
computation it just tells other systems
what to do blaze is not a a new idea
though it is the first thing that I will
have like it in Python
postgres has something on foreign data
wrappers which let you write sequel and
query things like a csv file or you can
also there's something called the sea
table which is like a column store for
postgres and you can write sequel
statements against that and it's not
implemented by the folks at post quests
it's a it's a totally separate project
the closest thing to blaze in another
system is deep fryer from our and deeper
as the syntax where you can sort of
chain operations together because the
input to each function is essentially a
data frame and with deep fryer you can
use things like sequel databases you can
use there's a librarian are called data
table which is sort of like a data frame
you can use standard our data frames and
then python has something called sequel
alchemy which most people in here are
probably familiar who's heard of sequel
came-- who's used sequel alchemy okay
cool so and co alchemy is kind of
similar to plays and except that it it
uses it only works with sequel in fact
plays actually uses seek welcome II
to work with sequel databases so getting
to the parts of blaze the first part is
expressions and those those described
what you want to compute and those
expressions have two parts they have to
have a name which is basically like a
Python identifier it's almost like a
variable name and they have something
called the data shape and data shape is
another library that's a very small
library annex and it's an extension it's
sort of an extension of the ideas in the
numpy d-type system so it lets you
describe both the shape of an array or a
table as well as as well as the types
and so in this case we have a million
row table with two columns name column
which is a string and amount was yours a
float 64
so you can see below i vanted here it
says name and then that's this is the
shape information typically like
something you would get a numpy ND of a
shape and type information which is
basically d-type we go back here so day
shape extends the d-type system to
support things like missing values
variable length dimensions it doesn't
actually sort of tell those systems how
to implement it but it allows you to
describe the metadata surrounding those
ideas
there are multiple kinds of expressions
there there's group fighters join we
support all the sort of standard
expressions that using pythons index
like arithmetic date arithmetic lots of
reductions very similar to pandas we
have like column and row stacking and
they're also others like is in and
pandas and so those are those are those
are expressions then the other side that
you have the other part plays you have
compute recipes and these are basically
saying when I do what I do the
expression given a particular data
source like a data frame a list of
tuples a sequel database app i spark
data frame and so on and the way these
things are written down is just like
tiny little recipes let's say okay I
have this expression with these inputs
now how do I do that computation
in this case I'm doing let's see i'm
doing join between two data frames a
pansy a frame and of course like the api
friend pandas is merge to to data frames
and you know what you're going to merge
on of course there's a lot of other
options to that as well these are sort
of these are not actual implementations
but fairly close to the actual and then
i have one again getting to spark
datagrams as input with a joint
expression i call it slightly
differently so this one one sort of
thing that alleviates you from having to
do is is learn a new API when you want
to use a different technology so maybe
you want to experiment with your small
scale data doing you know some algorithm
may be a sequel query and then you're
like okay well now I need to shove this
thing and spark and do it that way
these compute recipes work with existing
libraries like of course Python this
dump I raise data frames and I'm going
to show a small little demo just doing
like a group by operation on a redshift
cluster that we're running oh also I
wrote this little ipython extension
called auto time which basically will
run the time of anything you run it with
time I always call see you sorry let's
get rid of that guy I always end up
calling time after I've already done
something that's taken a long time so I
kind of wanted to just have that
automatically happen
and then I'm going to talk about odo in
a second so one thing I what's that o.o
use all the time it's kind of fun okay
so the way that I let's see do i sign of
this okay
the way you can initialize like a data
resource in blazes to actually say let's
see we called resource that's actually
from odo but all these things are
actually directly importable from plays
you say redshift I'm gonna have to go
get the URL in a second let's see
listen my history broccoli
there is okay
this nice URL
oops okay this is actually a seat
balcony engine that I can now sort of do
stuff with blazes this this object
called data so i should be a function
but oops they import it
okay thank you well let's see
alright connection issues joy
yeah that that's not that's not it will
use our automatically all right so I
have a have a backup I'll use my sort of
local postgres install
oh there we go okay all right so one
thing that's kind of nice about blaze
you know those that you can you can
explore your data set or your database
right so I have a couple of tables in
here NYC NYC PG bulk load and you can
sort of access them all with with dot
attribute access which is kind of nice
anything that blaze does for you is
inspected the D shape to see what
operations are possible so you won't be
able to do things like take the average
of a string column and pandas if you say
dot on your series it's going to tell
you you know basically the entire API
for all types and our what the columnist
lays limits this for you just guys
okay so actually just sucked out a
little bit of the data from sequel
alchemy and then shoved it into a data
frame then called like repper HTML on it
you can also look at the whole table you
can you can sort you can do group by
operations so you could say like GI NYC
passenger count actually so there are
some there are some funky values in the
passenger count so let's look at the max
of that guy six passengers in a taxi
that seems weird there's actually in
this is the subset that I've been in the
full day said there's something that
have like nine which is strange so let's
let's just get let's get a subset of
that will get
the data where the passenger count is
less than equal to four
and then we'll do a group on that thing
so you can have a passenger count and
then we'll say let's get the average tip
alright so it didn't actually compute in
five milliseconds it just built up an
expression when I representation okay so
yeah it took like 100 milliseconds so
you can you can and and this this sort
of expression this this expression will
work basically on anything that
that this data function accepts which is
like a seat welcome your I had data
frame list of tuples you can roll your
own thing if you one and so that's
that's sort of the demo there
now
let's go back to this so
one thing that is somewhat annoying
about having all these systems like well
I need to get between them right see
croc me is a fun case of stuff that when
you when you get out the actual result
and just delete this so let's call this
X a result alright so I have this like
selectable I'm gonna call execute now
what what is that thing there that is a
proxy of some kind a result proxy okay
okay maybe so so that's fine absent have
anything now that basically got all the
results and suck them into memory now
let's let's get get everything out Oh a
list of tuples
not so fast oops
ok
30 let's do this guy
it's a row proxy it's not actually a
couple so where do the proxies and they
don't this is sort of i actually really
like seek welcome i think it's a great
project but sometimes when you're doing
stuff like when you're developing
against the library or using in some
kind of developer capacity you feel like
you never actually get down to a Python
object so please just give me a data
frame and this is where odo comes in
odo is a library for trying things into
other things at its most basic super
generic level
just factor out from blaze in December
maybe of 2014 whatever right what's that
14 okay so whenever I would tell people
a lot what plays those they'd say oh
it's a side of converters and I'd say
it's not really a set of hers so is all
over the end right just a side of
converters odo handles like a very very
large variety conversions and they
there's interestings or paths you can
get through the the sort of network of
conversions that i'll show you guys in a
second but first i want to sort of get a
list of all the containers in the PI
data ecosystem so you guys gotta help me
out so I don't know them all I start you
off but I just saying a list so so just
shout out like different containers
jframe know by the way or eject master a
all right so all numb pint and stuff so
those things like spark day of frames
custom things that people's will roll on
their own
and we ought we want to move between
those things see Kwame has a like lot
like a large variety of things that you
can sort of move between right there's a
table selectable select statements
okay Django result sets we don't we
don't support that but we could you
could write that what Jeff okay oh yes
oh yeah we supports that's for sure we
use that a lot in testing because a lot
of these systems don't guarantee the
order results pi spark in particular so
simple things list couple that's kind of
a no-brainer but we also Jews or more
crazier things like converting a CSV on
hive to park a that takes a while I sort
of like to think of it as CP with types
and specific choose or PI data ecosystem
things
and lets you do things it lets you go
from from X to Y in the most efficient
way without exposing writing down each
conversion we're just kind of a nice
thing so before 10 toes in plays we had
like sort of the paralyzed listing of
all the possible conversions from each
particular type to every other type that
got really annoying and in in in the
case of something like David for him to
hive there's a step in between but so is
easy but you may not know every single
step so has anybody done this like
without odo trying to stick a data frame
onto a hive into a high table no okay
when going from Dave room to hive you
usually know each step right I know how
to do Dave frame to csv I know how to go
from csv to hive
odo sort of connects the dots for you
automatically and in a few minutes all
sort of show you how how that's done and
there's there's essentially one function
if you're a user he uses multiple
dispatch to figure out types in in
certain cases in this case it will
actually use that so it accepts sort of
different types as well as strings that
specify like I see graph me or I so
there's essentially one thing to
remember as far as function calls let's
let's sort of go through your steps for
something that's a little bit more
involved than sticking a data frame onto
a high cluster
we have some JSON and s3 bucket and one
rub that into a Postgres database let's
say it's a local Postgres database does
anybody have any like how would anyone
do this like does anyone want to say
like how they've done this or how they
might go about doing this
no okay
so this is the sort of approach I might
take I would bring down my s3 file into
a local temporary file and this is like
how you do with photo after you've done
your authentication so get your bucket
you get contents a file name I've gotten
a temporary file now I have to load the
temporary file into a frame with pans
read JSON does assume my JSON is sort of
like line too limited and nicely
formatted doesn't have nested data
they have to call that day for him to
eat CSV to to csv then I've take that
CSV and I have to say copy tea from blah
blah blah something something something
right so you don't just stick it in
there but well you do because you have
odo and over lets you do that you can
suck down that lets three file it shoves
it into our temporary file your system
wherever your system puts every files
and then you say okay I wanted to go
into this table and it will just do that
so like I said before each step is
usually easy okay but but the whole
thing ends up being like kind of
annoying
how does it actually work what's going
on behind the scenes
there's a network of conversions so when
you define a conversion function there's
a decorator that a pen that basically
shoves in the top of the types of the
pair the conversion pair into a
dictionary and multiple dispatch so it
looks that up whenever you call
essentially odo
this is the this is an example of a
single node and the saurian house
England it's an example of the pandas
dataframe a sub graph so I basically
took pandas dataframe looked at all the
things that were close to that in terms
of how many notes apart they were so you
can see jframe is is connected to has
this is connected to quite a few things
it's expected a series of course fixed
is something that we use to append and
read from hf store there's a chunking
mechanism built in dododo and then of
course numpy ray is also talked to like
lots of stuff so we support that as well
and the full monty is pretty big so you
can get some kind of interesting paths
when you trace through these things
there's also a cost mechanism built into
auto when you define conversion you can
say how expensive it is to go go go
through path
and you can extend it basically without
having to talk to me or anybody else
we're going to you can define it define
your own conversion function and odo
will just pick it up and put it into the
graph
let's see I think that that is it right
so you can countenance all it we just
had a release two weeks ago lots of bug
fixes there's documentation it plays up
high at org overlap I inorg and we would
love some contributors as well currently
I'm the only person working on auto in a
foolish time capacity so yeah happy to
take questions yeah
so you have to write your own sort of
custom function to do that mo doesn't
handle so in certain cases it's very
difficult to preserve metadata 11 cases
like time Delta's so pythons a time
delta object only has microsecond
precision whereas numpy has like down to
80 seconds or something like that so in
those cases we don't preserve the
metadata
you just write your own custom
yes so how hard was it to write all
these different
each one basically it's its own separate
you know gruesome battle
or it was there like one generic method
that you just have to tweak
that sort of depends on the support of
that library for going to that
particular object but in certain cases
we like we leverage the graph that lets
you sort of like if something knows how
to go to an umpire array and that number
i right knows how to go the other thing
but the original thing doesn't know how
to go the other thing then it will just
take that path so not hard in some cases
it's sort of there's one sort of core
thing that does the aeration through the
graph looping through and just calling
every every conversion function until
you reach the end
yeah so we there's no automatic
out of memory conversion unless you
start with something that's already out
of memory so if i have a csv file that
doesn't fit into memory it will chunk
into something like if you're going to
an in-memory container then there's
nothing that we can do right you're
saying like read this into memory but if
you're saying if you're going from like
CSV to h5 pi then odo will chunk into
the h5 pi file automatically and in
general the sorry on the graph these red
the red nodes are basically indicate
that those things are out of core and so
once you once you end up in one of those
red notes auto will drop out all the
things that aren't out of core
and we'll try to try to do the
conversion within that that path with
everything that crap there's other hand
somewhere okay
so if you're out of memory
Oh
yeah we're actually just bid will
actually just do take that sub graph and
use that to compute the shortest path so
it drops off everything else that isn't
out of memory it was there another hand
yeah oh sorry the guy in the back blue
shirt
it's mighty pretty narrow question I was
hmm
we're using my sequel
ok so my sequel doesn't like officially
support writing headers it's kind of a
weird thing anyway that sounds like a
bug but what where was it coming from
okay sounds like a bug let's let's talk
afterward yes oh so yeah
nope
so pandas has like a lot of API that
blaze will probably never influent just
because pandas is uber magic especially
around my group I apply and just apply
in general so another case is resampling
functionality blaze could grow that but
as of right now you can't really do
resampling in in blaze that and you can
do that in pandas
so I would say most like most like
relational database things are there the
only the big exception being window
functions as far as a
pandas goes there's there's there's just
like a lot more API and in hand us that
blaze will probably never expose one
nice thing about is that if you wanted
those things and we aren't going to do
them then it's certainly possible it's
just like happy to subscribe without
likes or affecting the core of blazes
when you know but allowing you to have
maybe something custom
so yeah
did you have another question
besides what would make
is the cost on all the
no no it's it's it's kind of a unitless
cost number you just serve a sign like
large if it's constantly smaller less
costly it's a second ordinal scale
sure yeah you just give it a number yeah
you just like in the converted decorator
you say cost equals something like a
number
yeah it's it takes the shortest path
through the fin de Graaff Casey
no but there's a way to get that
information so converges like an
instance of a special class that has a
method called path
you give it the starting node thing you
want to end up at and it will give you a
little basically give you a list of
tuples where it's a conversion path then
function there's a type a Type B
function and then it'll keep giving you
that until it gets to the final edge
cool any other questions yes
sorry can you just repeat it
there's a small red to the like blaze
interpreter but it's like tends to maybe
ones of milliseconds mostly systems
there's going to be a large cost
involved in serializing stuff you know
with the exception of like numpy and
pandas sometimes or most of the time but
but yeah so it's it's a pretty small
cost yeah yes sometimes there's a path
for numpy erase the data frame from
pandas stuff I wrote that and I haven't
put it in to data auto yet but that
would be really really easy in fact a
new contributor could probably do it any
other any other questions